[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
on va revenir sur la réélection des
manuels macron les conséquences qu'elles
peuvent avoir peut-être aussi se
projeter sur des élections législatives
et pour parler de toute cette actualité
véronique jérôme bonjour bouchaud vous
êtes maître de conférences en sciences
de gestion à l'université paris saclay
et vous êtes la co créatrice et la
responsable du site élections scop
élections scop seul signal vais donner
au mois de janvier l'élection de
emmanuel macron avec 58,4 pour cent des
voix c'est ça 58 6 58 6 c'est à dire
exactement le le résultat c'est pas des
sons d'argent c'est ça des scientifiques
ou des leçons avec l'obscurité tester
jachère lajoinie bonjour bonjour
éditeurs et vous allez vous avez suivi
et évidemment cette élection
romanesque
réveil matin nuit ou jours de
conférences à l'université versailles
saint quentin en droit public bruno
mediène bonjour enchanté alors on a
failli faire un débat avec vous
la semaine dernière face à face à un
report of the air est né ils sont
dégonflés on va dire ça comme ça
allez savoir je ne sais pas ils disent
que leur candidate avait été maltraité
par les médias alors vous êtes député de
modems de la 9e circonscription des
civils c'est une circonscription
intéressant parce que dans laquelle dans
des petits villages marine le pen fait
des scores assez important au premier
tour louis n'aille pas au deuxième
finalement ça m'a un petit peu rassurés
on est resté finalement sur l'étiage
qu'on avait
en 2017 c'est un peu les mêmes villages
autour de bonnières de toute cette
partie de ma circonscription qui était
encore sur l'axé seine qui est toujours
sur l'axé seine et qui était très
industrialisée et qui a été totalement
des instrus des désindustrialisé et
depuis le vote rassemblement national
percole alors c'est à dire y ait une
augmentation
elle est moins forte la fin soit moins
fort qu'au plan national puisqu'elle est
à -2 -2 40% vendent veut dans votre
circonscription
non mais ça on a eu un petit coup au
coeur quand on a vu les résultats du
premier tour parce que là on est des
fameuses petite pastille bleue était
très nombreuses sur le territoire et
finalement ça s'est complètement
inversée pour revenir à ce qu'on avait
connu en 2017 c'est finalement sur la
circonscription ai dit qu'à l'entendre
il bon jour ils ont fait durer jsqu'à tv
78 et on va venir avec vous justement
c'est ce qui se passe dans ce
département mais peut-être on va d'abord
commencer de base ou général avec ce
retour sur sur une réélection
[Musique]
alors faut rappeler que c'est une
première dans l'histoire de la vème
république la réélection d'un président
qui exerce réellement le pouvoir c'est à
dire hors cohabitation c'est la première
depuis que le quinquennat de ré élection
d'un président de république et il faut
rappeler quand même que emmanuel macron
entame un deuxième mandat de président
de la république qu'à 44 ans
et quand même c'est assez étonnant
si on se pose la question à quoi à quoi
est due cette réélection je vais pas me
dire à quoi c'est dû mince et du détour
d'abord peut-être un duel qui a été
longuement a voulu par le président de
la république en considérant qu'
effectivement il y avait beaucoup plus
de chance de gagner une élection quand
on sait qu'on est face à une candidate
qui est plus dans le rejet donc on est
sur un vote qui va aller dans vingt vote
utile le rejet le tout sauf marine le
pen un marché en 2017 il a un nouveau
marché cette année il faut pas il faut
pas se le cacher
oui il ya bien il ya plus le front
républicain
totalement un
réflexe républicain elle est à 8 points
de moins 66% 58 mais en même temps il ya
déjà donc le côté un peu facile de la
chose ça c'est une chose et en même
temps on s'aperçoit quand même que pour
donner de la puissance à cette élection
et à ce résultat pour considérer qu
emmanuel macron a véritablement gagné je
rappelle plusieurs éléments les sondages
tout d'abord qui annonçait que deux
français sur trois voulaient entre
guillemets sortir le sortant dont qui
atteint même n'y avait pas oui il ya la
pioneer de dégager il ya cette
atmosphère de dégagisme parce que
candidat à sa façon aussi anti système
ni de droite ni de gauche donc ça ça
perdure il ya donc cet aspect là il ya
une une popularité d'exécutifs qui alors
vous parlez de nos modèles
économétriques pour en dire deux mots
ici mais de façon très simple on a
calculé une tendance longue et il y à un
seuil minimum pour la réélection c'est à
dire que le seuil c'était 41% à 41 % de
popularité d'exécutif c'est le minimum
qui entre autre élément peut garantir la
réélection est donc là emmanuel macron
et à 41,42 vais vraiment sur le seuil du
seuil sur le mini
ça montre qu'il n'y a des éléments qui
n'était pas a priori
facilitateur c'est pas favorable mais il
a malgré tout réussi maintenant bien
évidemment le premier le deuxième tour
forcément on a cette adhésion est ce que
c'est un vote d'adhésion c'est la
question du rectorat voilà une question
qui va se passer mais je reviens et je
vais interroger peut-être brawn williams
là dessus sur quelque chose que vous
dites vous dites ça duels qu'il a voulu
mais
j'entends beaucoup cette phrase mais
c'est de france et qui
alors qu'ils ne voulaient pas dans l'est
dans les sondages ce qui précède et
l'élection exeo goûte pas d'un match
retour mais au fond ça corresponde à une
sociologie française
parce que
ce première élection il avait dit si
marine le pen est en face de moi c'est à
cause des deux prédécesseurs qui nous a
menés là et ce sera un échec dans cinq
ans que je me retrouve avec le front
national on peut considérer que là il ya
quand même un échec que par deux sa part
venant souvent dix ans il sert duel qui
l'a voulu est ce qu'on veut des choses
la légitimité ou pas du président de la
république sur cette élection d'abord
yade sur le social sur ce quoi alors y'a
pas moi j'ai pas de souci ya pas de
doute il ya d'autant moins de doute que
je crois une juge et un chiffre en tête
j'espère que je vais pas dire de bêtises
sur ceux qui ont voté pour une année le
maquereau deuxième tour 58% d'entre eux
ont voté pour le projet et 42% contre
marine le pen donc ca soit un petit peu
plus la légitimité deuxième chose est ce
que c'est nous qui avons installé le
duel avec marine le pen je peine à le
croire si vous me permettez l'expression
parce que oui il ya eu cette forme de
effectivement on mais on a mis en 2017
pouvoir quelqu'un qui est sur un axe
central qui prône le ni droite ni gauche
ou de droite et gauche en même temps
appelez ça comme vous voulez en tout cas
nous moi mon modèle c'est quelque chose
qui me va très bien françois bayrou
avait tenté avant lui et du coup on a vu
on a pu voir au cours de ce quinquennat
l'extrême fragilité des partis dits de
gouvernement le ps d'un côté qui était
déjà bien mal en point en 2017 et les
républicains derrière moi j'ai vécu à
l'assemblée nationale cinq années de
mandat j'ai vu des choses quand même que
je ne pensais pas voir au cours la vème
république voir le bloc des républicains
voter certains amendements ou certains
textes en totale phase avec la france
insoumise on n'avait jamais vu ça on
n'imaginait pas quand on est arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale que y aurait cette
espèce de regroupement
rassemblement national mis à part
puisqu'il n'avait pas de groupe
parlementaire ça joue aussi il faut bien
faut bien le ciel vous avez moins de
temps de parole que les autres il ya eu
quand même un rassemblement total des
oppositions contre emmanuel macron sur
beaucoup de sujets dont des sujets si je
prends les républicains qui était plutôt
avec l'égalité plus de la caserne est
totalement donc voilà il ya un an venir
tout le monde a sa réponse il ya un
échec de nos marques parce qu'on n'a pas
su rassembler les français c'est sûr
c'est apporter le vote sur les extrêmes
mais pas que sur marine le pen regard
des deux premiers tours avec jean luc
mélenchon personnes s'attendaient à le
voir aussi haut que ça les sondages
n'avaient pas prévu voilà donc oui on a
notre part de responsabilité mais je
pense qu'on peut pas endosser à nous
seuls la responsabilité
alors ce qui est vrai c'est que raphaël
mata des vies on peut dire au faux que
emmanuel macron réussi sa stratégie
d'aller point un peu sur la droite et la
gauche républicaine puisqu'on voit les
scores de dire pathétique qui ont été
faits par
par valérie pécresse ou pas anne hidalgo
mais on peut dire aussi que c'est pas ce
deuxième tour et correspond enfin au
fond une sociologie française non c'est
à dire il ya une coupure de la france
vieillit vous avez une france des
métropoles une france qui va plutôt bien
et une france plus rurales ou plus
périphériques qui va plutôt mal oui
c'est vrai que les que les tailles des
sondages des enquêtes d'opinion le
montrent
il est vrai que le vote le pen et je
vais mettre dans l'instant ensemble le
vote le pen et mélenchon est plutôt
caractérisée par un vote populaire si si
vraiment on s'accroche au aux enquêtes
d'opinion un vote populaire peu diplômés
rural
effectivement périphériques et donc je
pense que ce vote des extrêmes ou
extrême droite extrême gauche
est le fruit d'une convergence
finalement d'une sorte de colère de
frustration d'un ensemble de
revendications et d'une mauvaise
perception au site delà de l'offre
politique je pense que ces perfs que ce
vote là est le fruit d'un
constat d'une mauvaise représentation sa
set ça c'est très important les les
français en tout cas une partie des
français ne sont plus concernés ne sont
plus représentés par le personnel
politique ça c'est un premier point est
donc ça génère des frustrations et donc
un vote de colère à votre d'extrême de
rejet après le vote le vote macron
effectivement catégorie que
classiquement il est considéré comme un
vote urbain et aisé
diplôme et non le voit d'emblée il ya
des tableaux qui monterait à très bien
fois en france et on voit aussi dans les
dîners parce que finalement dans le
département des yvelines les zones
urbaines et les grandes villes iguazu et
emmanuel macron les zones rurales ou
plutôt aisée comme la vallée de
chevreuse la plaine de versailles autour
de grandes villes rambouillet maul las
c'est plutôt un vote macron mais dès
lors qu'on s'approche de l'eure-et-loir
et de et de l'eure et de la vallée de
seine où c'est un peu plus populaires
ouvriers parfois au premier tour marine
le pen faut le dire quand même faut le
rappeler arrive en tête à agen et à
gargenville flins c'est le jeu c'est
l'usiné renault de passer au second tour
elle perd ses deux communes elle n'est
plus en tête dans ces deux communes là
et après dès lors qu'on s'approche de
leur dans les petits villages ruraux
bain marie le pen est en tête avec
jérôme justement tant qu'économiste vous
avez étudié ça justement les les vois
bien votre carte lundi que l' année un
peu un peu un peu coupé mais on nous
parlait avant d'une banane bleue c'est à
dire de cet arc 7 2 2 hier que le cercle
et là on a encore un morceau d'abadan
bleus qui montre la correspondance entre
le vote front national et ses zones où
il ya un taux de chômage plus élevé que
la moyenne où il ya des difficultés
économiques etc et là on a encore sakic
qui persiste et je crois que marine le
pen a fait son meilleur score façon
soldes score régional où elle est en
tête c'est en région paca donc on a
vraiment d'aider des éléments de de la
sociologie la socio économie
mais l'amateurisme jeu par des régions
sur le
fond soit là il est donc il ya bien ce
lien et après on pourrait même ajouter
une insécurité de sentiment d'insécurité
qui est corrélé avec le fort taux de
chômage qui est corrélé avec tous ses
aspects donc là ça peut s'expliquer et
quand je disais tout à l'heure emmanuel
macron a voulu ce duel enfin je me suis
mal exprimé s'étonnera qu'il était
d'accord berline mais vous allez c'est
pas ce que c'est mais a priori c'est
vrai que cette france coupée en deux
elle persiste et c'est ainsi que l'appui
le mieux s'exprimer le on annonce est
aussi un fort taux d'abstention qui
s'est révélé d'ailleurs exact un taux
d'abstention important et donc
normalement les électeurs qu'ils vont
voter c'est qu'ils ont je dirais ils
sont dans une asymétrie du blâme ils
vont voter plus enfin en termes relatifs
et vont voter plus pour revendiquer pour
réclamer pour exprimer une colère que
pour dire on est satisfait on a très peu
évoqué le bilan du sortant on a très peu
évoqué les bons points on n'a pas
entendu mais voilà on n'a pas entendu un
électeurs fn un électeur pardon lrm dire
le bilan des manuels macron me motive
ainsi aller voter pour macro par contre
dans l'opposition dans les oppositions
c'est cette colère si le fait d' adam
bielan qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
attentes des attentes qui justifie et
qui fait qu'il y a cette incitation à
aller voter cette motivation donc je
pense qu alors c'est sûr celle sur le
bilan
dans les meetings qu'il a fait manuel da
cruz cette façon on l'a fait on l'a fait
glv suivi lui des ford est quand même
c'est le drôle de paradoxe c'est qu'il y
avait quand même un bilan je vais
essayer d'être le plus objectif possible
la crise n'est pas négatif à mon sens
d'abord un le président afghan avait été
élu sur un projet en 2017 il arrivait on
va dire quasi de nulle part avec un
projet il a été lu sur ce projet et son
projet il l'a réalisé où il est en cours
de réalisation à 76% je crois qu'on n'a
pas vu ça lors des dernier quinquennat
depuis très très longtemps ça c'est la
première chose donc certains des
français peuvent dire oui il n'a pas
fait le job mais il a fait non mais
certains des français qui va que c'est
vous mais il a fait le job pour lequel
il a été élu à 76%
malgré la pandémie malgré les gie
majeure n'est malgré la guerre
maintenant qu'on est aux portes de
l'europe ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point sur l'aspect social on
est très certainement pas allé
suffisamment loin mais quand on regarde
tout ce qui touche aux vrais quotidien
des français que les français certains
ont oublié je vous prends juste un
exemple qui pour moi était quelque chose
de très important les familles
monoparentales
la plupart du temps des femmes le fait
de pouvoir récupérer sa pension
alimentaire directement par la caf et
c'est l'état qui se chargent du conjoint
qui n'appelle pas eh bien ça je peux
vous dire que pour le quotidien de
toutes ces femmes qui sont en difficulté
par rapport à ce set cet aspect là c'est
très important mais j'ai le plein de
petites choses il n'y a pas eu en fait
y'a pas une énorme une grosse réforme a
pas la réforme du travail la réforme de
l'assurance chômage mais il n'y a pas eu
de grosses réformes
sociales a eu la très petite chose
sociale qui ont été faites
l'augmentation des minima sociaux tout
ça ça a été fait quand vous faites le
listing il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
été faites et moi j'ai un peu
l'impression alors je vais pas me faire
que des amis que gâteau avaler n'a plus
de saveur mais
mais vous devrez parce que quand on
regarde et son âge et quand on regarde
ce qu'on appelle l'état de grâce à cette
période donnée mou de tout juste élu
normalement le président doit bénéficier
d'une madjer et courtois
trois cours de toute la 5e et on voit
bien qu'il ya un côté un peu
les lecteurs reçoit mais il va pas
récompensés et dans les indices de
popularité on l'a vu très vite donc
finalement les réformes ont été mises en
route mais les prédécesseurs ont fait la
même chose il essaie de lancer les
réformes mais ça ne se retrouve pas dans
un état de grâce qui aurait dû être
confortable qui doit permettre de faire
plus encore parce que l'état de grâce à
signifie que le nombre des satisfaits
dépasse le nombre des mécontents donc
quand vous avez 60 40 60 % de satisfaits
40 % de mécontents vous avez les marges
de manoeuvre nécessaires pour mettre en
forme en place des réformes qui font mal
qu'ils vont demander à déstocker delà de
la réputation des stockées là quand vous
n'avez pas 7,7 stocks et cette liberté
de manoeuvre vous êtes déjà un petit peu
plus contre un sur vos ambitions de
réforme si vous ajoutez ce que vous nous
dites que l'électeur finalement on se
dit bon finalement c'est une récompense
c'est normal il n'en tient pas bénéfices
à l'exécutif ça rajoute encore ce
sentiment et mais c'est vrai et on peut
penser aussi que lors d'une réélection
l'état de grâce est encore bourse
il a peut-être
fait pas ça pose des problèmes qu'on
peut aborder tout de suite qui est qui
celui d'institutions c'est à dire que
une fois et lui alors évidemment un
président est élu il a été élu avec 58
vient aussi pour son bon assez largement
comme ça mais une fois élu il est quand
même ramené à l'étiage de ce qu'il a eu
au premier tour c'est à dire un peu
moins de 30% et quand vous avez un peu
moins de 30% voisin quand même 70 % des
gens qui sont contre vous dès que vous
appliquez votre police ça c'est un vrai
problème c'est ou pour dîner de la
république de la 5e ça a été comme ça en
revanche on parlait de représentativité
si vous qui parlait tout à l'heure il
est impératif sur ce mandat là qu'on
change des choses en terme de
représentativité et vous le savez
d'où la proportionnelle où on est des
fervents partisans de la proportionnelle
parce que je ne crois pas encore une
fois pour avoir vécu ce mandat au
palais-bourbon je ne crois pas qu un
parlement fort c'est-à-dire où il n'y a
pas forcément une majorité pléthorique
illégale comme ça a été le cas du
premier quinquennat je pense qu'un
parlement doit être fort rend de facto
le gouvernement fort par la voix
effectivement des débats démocratiques
et rend le président encore plus fort
donc on n'a pas à avoir peur de la
proportionnelle est d'ailleurs ce
corrompu et ce sera sans doute d'une
d'une autre façon de gouverner il va
falloir faire des alliances et des
majorités 6 et d'une part du principe
qui a amené emmanuel macron ont
finalement au pouvoir de dire une idée
est bonne parce qu'elle est bonne parce
qu'elle vient de la droite ou de la
gauche mais parce qu'elle s'applique à
la réalité de la société française et à
la réalité du moment et bien on doit pas
avoir peur de ça on doit pas avoir peur
de la proportionnelle ne va pas avoir
peur de ce que sur certains textes et
des coalitions qui se passe au choc au
sein du palais bourbon pour amender le
texte l'améliorer en faire un texte plus
fort encore pour les citoyens et je
reviens ce que vous disiez c'est à dire
de ce que vous avez votre expérience et
dire que vous avez vu le groupe allait
s'allier avec avec elfi par exemple mais
si on peut on peut on peut supposer que
même si une réforme de la retraite même
si l air est plutôt d'accord avec ça ils
peuvent voter tout à fait contre avec ça
j'étais content s'ils deviennent plus
nombreux conseils tels qu'un tel qu'un
c'est un problème ça pose un problème de
la faim de d'applicabilité des réformes
et de démocratie c'est vrai que vous
êtes favorable des rafales à la
proportionnelle je suis favorable depuis
peu
converti
c'est à dire que pendant très longtemps
quand j'étais étudiant et même quand
j'étais dans mes débuts dans le début de
mes enseignements j'étais farouchement
au favorable au scrutin uninominal
majoritaire à deux tours est
progressivement jeu depuis la stabilité
qu'il appellerait ça une force au
gouvernement et donc au chef de l'état
si les majorités sont concordantes mais
progressivement je me suis aperçu depuis
trois-quatre en réalité qu' il y avait
ce que vous venez de dire dans la
société française mais depuis un certain
nombre d'années en réalité un déficit de
d'acceptabilité d'acceptabilité delà du
résultat démocratique d'une part et
d'acceptabilité de la décision de la
décision politique de la décision du
gouvernant et il faut retrouver il faut
trouver parlons des nouveaux outils qui
permettent justement aux citoyens aux
français de se reparler de la décision
publique de s'emparer du processus
décisionnel et d'accepter ces je pense
que l'un dé nous le plus important c'est
l'acceptation l'acceptation du résultat
démocratique et donc la proportionnelle
vous venez de le dire absolument je suis
d'accord avec vous la proportion est
finalement on ne doit plus en avoir peur
je pense que les le compromis la
négociation permettra malgré tout de se
retrouver sur un certain nombre de
sujets essentiels qui feront peut-être
pas contre consensus dans tout cas des
sujets importants et à charge pour le
gouvernement d'essayer de trouver à
droite à gauche au centre les forces qui
lui permettront justement de mener à
bien cette réforme et ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est de voir qu'il ya
une perte de de leadership d'autorité on
a vu des grands présidents avec une
autorité pompidou giscard mitterrand
de gaulle aujourd'hui le personnel
politique n'est voué - si vous voulez -
charismatique et donc il a besoin
j'étais peut-être une des ddd raison de
l'élection
des manuels pas qu'on peut poser vous
êtes la plus grande banque de rippert
des 2,7 à bloquer
non mais c'est vrai qu'à une faiblesse
non est-ce qu'il veut pas de faiblesse
de la concurrence vient quand on voit le
débat avec marine le pen au bout de
trois minutes on voit bien que forcément
à la hauteur
et il ya des gens qui se présentent à
l'est on a l'impression quand même que
n'importe qui peut se présenter
aujourd'hui l'élection présidentielle
avec l'idée de dire aux spots président
absolue bouazzi note absolument c'est
mais c'est le drame induits par les
primaires c'est vrai que déjà cette
première élection où des gens des
militants ou
apparenté certain militantisme vote pour
quelqu'un
sans aucun
sens aucune vision de se dire oui mais
la personne pour laquelle on va voter
est ce qu'elle pourra faire face au
président maintenant est ce qu'elle
pourra faire face un candidat
intelligente du parti socialiste elle
fois non c'est pas possible donc on a
des candidats c'est une sorte de
nivellement par le bas j'ai listé 74
vous avez mitterrand giscard charbon se
dire 2 2 qui seront reprises république
1 un premier ministre 80 les trois
présidents de républiques mitterrand
giscard chirac
enfin alors on pourrait multiplier après
jospin étaient des radeaux s'ajoutent à
ça c'est vrai que ce problème des
primaires suzuki qui débouche vraiment
sûr sur des primaires l'absence du
leadership sur des candidatures elles
bah oui parce que ce qu'on disait la
dernière fois je veux dire les seuls
partis qui ont un candidat qui ne
sont bien évidemment pas mes faveurs que
ce soit à l'extrême gauche ou l'extrême
droite cdc des partis qui n'ont pas
organisé de prix mais encore une fois on
n'imagine pas mélenchon dire tiens si on
faisait une primaire pour savoir si je
suis la bonne personne n'est une année
on n'imagine pas les quatre musées en
dire bien on va faire une primaire tient
jordan est ce que tu veux te battre
contre moi donc dans la côte dans notre
cour des quadeurs
personnes en place mais oui imaginons
quand ils vont se retirer qu'est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des primaires qui
montre l'aspect c'est ce qu'ils vont
s'organiser mais mais mais mais quand on
voit ça c'est tout à fait c'est tout à
fait content quand on voit où parti
socialiste est là se parle même pas des
idées mais mais mais c'est sur la façon
qu'ils organisaient cette primaire
notons enfin il ya ce départ il ya
quelqu'un qui voit de la lumière mais
celle on avait un peu le cas aussi avec
xavier bertrand qui tout d'un coup
détient 9 buts je me verrais bien
président je me présente et il court
circuit tout le monde anne hidalgo qui
sont pousser des ailes à co2 de supra de
sa capacité à embouteiller paris
maubeuge pour peut-être au goûter la
france allez on y va
également il avait dit je vais sacrifier
et jeunes acquièrent en france que j'ai
fait à paris
et tout et tout le monde jamais de 21 ce
soit au fond deux états aux marchés
une fois avec oloron la marche une fois
avec toute la colonne à cette réserve
près qu'il a quand même donner des clefs
du parti à martine aubry et que donc il
a eu des fraudeurs contre lui qui l'a
empêché de gouverner donc en réalité n'a
pas vraiment marché
sur les primaires enfin c'est un camp
monde on le disait delva évince encore
le répéter la lors de la dernière
émission c'est que c'est un système à la
base américain qu'on a impacté en france
et ça marche aux états unis parce que
c'est historiquement c'est le système
qui est comme ça c'est culturel et c'est
depuis le début des institutions
américaines comme ça en france ça ne
marche pas cependant savoir comment le
rn et la france insoumise vont désigner
un candidat aux prochaines
présidentielles une fois qu'il aura plus
de leaders
historiques
va faire l'exégèse du fonds de ça mais
je pense que bardella tout à fait les
capacités et il sera plutôt supérieurs
marina était en débat et
intellectuellement tout cas le seul nom
qu'à la cité dans son discours de
dimanche c'est quand même un signe selon
qui ressort pour l'instant la part
de m
oui j'ai tout défendre qui incarnera le
leader juifs issus de ces questions de
leadership dans un parti vrai dommage
parce que je pense que ça s'organise
dans les dents les deux partis extrêmes
et ils ont bien raison de le faire parce
qu'on s'aperçoit les effondrements des
partis dits de gouvernement c'est aussi
parce qu'ils n'ont pas su préparer la
suite à l'issue de la défaite de nicolas
sarkozy il ya personne personne qui a
été soutenue par l'ensemble du parti a
soutenu par l'ensemble du parti pour
avancer ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose je suis désolé de le dire
aussi brutalement mais
certains qui sont partis de chez les
élèves mais comme certains qui sont
partis du ps disent tous la même chose
on a arrêté de bosser on a arrêté de
produire des idées on s'est contenté de
suivre le lectorat or un homme politique
ou une femme politique qui veut se
présenter à la présidence il est pas là
pour suivre l'électorat est là pour
entrer entraîné les lecteurs il ya plus
de courroie d'entraînement au ps il ya
plus de courroie d'entraînement à l air
c'est là il me faut ce qui se pose des
questions je dis pas qu'il ya une
courroie d'entraînement qui marche super
bien forcément chez mm macro ce
quinquennat la devra prouver qu'elle
existe c'est-à-dire qu'on devra faire
effectivement des choses qu'on n'a pas
pu faire pendant les cinq ans c'est
toute la partie sociale un peu plus
forte que ce qu'on était prévu au début
de au début de son premier quinquennat
et qui a été un peu empêché on va le
dire par les crises mais là il faut il
va falloir sur ce quinquennat qu'il
arrive à rassembler et qu'ils fassent
des mesures qui fasse que les gens qui
sont tout en bas se sentent considérés
et je vais juste un petit point sur le
rural et les territoires y est les
urbains ça fait quand même moi j'entends
parler de ça depuis 40 ans au métropolis
tous pas seulement l'économie la culture
le sport tout ce que vous voulez mais
trop policé et on a dit aux territoires
qui sont pas dans les métropoles lundi
vous inquiétez pas va y avoir un simple
vous allez en bénéficier un moment ou un
autre or les allemands oui alors ça
personne ne le voit venir ce qui change
un petit peu la donne a aujourd'hui sur
le plan de relance c'est que les projets
qui sont portés en priorité par le
gouvernement sont les projets qui
s'installe sur les territoires le but
c'est quoi c'est que les gens
travaillent et vivent au même endroit
dans un rayon on va dire de 10 15 20 km
n'est pas avoir comme on le voit en
ile-de-france moi sur ma circonscription
je le vois bien les gens se tapent
s'endort l'argent ils me font en voiture
parce que je suis désolé il n'y a pas de
moyens valérie les transports en commun
ne fonctionnent pas bien on va pas me
dire le contraire la ligne j la ligne n
avec cet art on n'en parle pas parce que
c'est des lignes catastrophique et donc
vous rajoutez à un sentiment d'exclusion
parce que vous êtes obligés d'aller à la
capitale pour bosser et puis des fois
vous avez des boulots qui sont pas
terribles
deuxième exclusion vous faites quand
même son band par jour simplement pour
aller gagner des fois des clopinettes
juste un point sur ce que ce que vous
dites quand on voit le parti des
républicains le parti socialiste
finalement aujourd'hui quel est l'espace
politique dans lequel ils peuvent se
placer pas ce que vous dites que il
n'avance pas d'idées mais avancer des
idées sans reproduire ce que fait manuel
maquereau ou ce que font les extrêmes
c'est un peu compliqué donc ça c'était
sur la première chose n'avait que la
deuxième chose pour rebondir sur ruraux
et territoires moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron a
définitivement
aboli le clivage gauche droite pour
mettre un clivage plutôt
mondialisation contre nationaliste je
pense qu'aujourd'hui et c'est les
politistes dans leur analyse les
politistes depuis plusieurs années déjà
prédisent la fin du clivage gauche
droite est plutôt un clivage entre
nationalistes mondialistes d'un côté sur
une ligne horizontale et une ligne
verticale où il ya plutôt liberté en bas
à égalité en eau et les partis
politiques aussi dans ceux dans ce cadre
donc enfin voila c'est une analyse sur
la fin du clivage rien de définitif
géval gauche-droite correspondait plus
tout à fait à la sociologie française on
a commencé à aborder le deuxième
question c'est à dire communiqué
essentielle benoît c est comment
gouverner
[Musique]
et je verrai ce que vous disiez sur le
manque d'idées c'est vrai que quand on
voit par exemple anne hidalgo
arrivé à la présidentielle mais on
sentait qu'il avait pas un début de
commencement 10 des programmes par
exemple s'était lancé cet été
les héros d'hier comme ça on va doubler
le savez que les enseignants parce qu'il
ya quand même deux autres campagnes mois
qui nous terrifier en me disant mais
franchement c'est laisser la part belle
finalement au programme de rupture des
extrémistes qui eux aussi économiquement
dire des choses qui ne sont pas tenables
mais qui ont un vrai programme de
rupture pour le coup qu'on l'acceptent
ou pas c'est un vrai profil de rupture
et les partis dits de gouvernement enfin
diallo qui rentre en campagne nous on va
doubler le salaire des profs c'est
quelqu'un uniquement c'est pas possible
de l'autre côté valérie pécresse à y
rentrer je crois qu'elle est rentrée
avec la territorialisation des peines
c'est à dire est que vous allez prendre
plus cher si vous commettez un délit
06/10 canal j moi je vis est une chose
c'est que ceux qui font des délits vont
pédaler plus tôt à neuilly du coup
puisque les pelles sont moindres et éco
qu'ils ont peut-être un petit peu plus
heureux dans leurs méfaits mais voilà on
ne peut pas partir en campagne en
racontant des choses comme ça c'est vrai
ces quatorze l'impression qu'il ya une
pression de certains quand même c'est
c'est eh ben oui mais je comprends même
pas qu'on puisse avancer ses idées là
pour répondre sur la droite après je
suis je sais je parle pour répondre à
droite et la gauche de gouvernement
on l'a bien vu à l'assemblée nationale
il ya
sur le texte important qu'on a voté on
était on nous on avait l'habitude de
dire si la droite râler que la l'extrême
gauche râle c'est que nous on est mieux
c'est pas si mal que ça ok il y avait il
ya des pas large il ya un petit espace
pour pousser un peu plus fort ce qui est
la droite alors pas forcément le côté
droite identitaire mais même au niveau
économique même au niveau des retraites
par exemple quand une journée on est
pareil au ps mais ne se sont pas pareils
de sa du petit plus qui ferait la
différence chez eux par rapport à un axe
central ils se sont un peu je suis
désolé de dire moi je concert qu'ils
sont un peu noyé tout seul alors après
son entrée dans je tape sur macro ça va
me rapporter
verdict j'aimerais justement vous
parliez tout à l'heure de ce fait cette
coupure en inde de la france
baladée lieu des premiers d'un des
premiers travaux à effectuer c'est
justement peut-être de 6 de recoudre un
peu les morceaux alors il ya des
intentions mais moi j'ai pour habitude
de dire qu' on ne décrète pas on ne
décrète pas un taux de croissance on ne
décrète pas un taux de chômage le
pouvoir en place ne peut pas décréter il
peut juste donné les incitations il ne
veut pas dire voilà ça va mieux je vous
le garantis et il ya un autre point pour
revenir sur eux en 2005 le mans sur ce
qu'on disait concernant les programmes
je crois qu'il ya deux types de d'hommes
politiques alors j'ai pas caractérisé
mais il ya deux types d'hommes
politiques il ya l'homme politique qui
veut à tout prix gagner les élections il
va faire un programme pour gagner les
élections et ça s'arrête là et puis le
politique qui croit en ses valeurs et on
irait dans les réformes qu'il a envie de
mettre en place et il propose un
programme qu'il mettre en place une fois
qu'il aura gagné des élections c'est à
dire que gagner les élections c'est le
moyen de mettre en place son programme
il y croit c'est pour ça que parfois on
a cette impression que ceux qui ne
croient pas vraiment en leur programme
ils le font uniquement comme ça c'est à
court terme pour gagner l'élection pour
avoir les voix après
cet aspect là les raisons mais et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui est une des
difficultés de l'élection sous la 5e
république au suffrage universel c'est
que
si on est raisonnable et modérée on a
moins de chances d'être entendus quand
on fait un programme cette saison face à
l'aide du sang et des larmes
finalement voilà il ya mieux il faut
alors compliqué d'avoir le juste milieu
il faut à la fois une fois considérer
les lecteurs en tant que individu
rationnel alors la rationalité de
l'électeur est limité on dit qu'il est
myope qui doit à très court terme il va
s'attacher à ce qui était fait à court
terme il ne se projette pas sur le long
terme mais il ya quand même dans les
électeurs il ya des parents qui ont des
enfants il ya un lien intergénérationnel
on ne peut pas dire je vais accepter du
quoi qu'il en coûte à nouveau remis sur
la table et puis ceux qui paieront la
facture ce seront les enfants de mes
enfants donc là il ya quand même des
considérations qui doivent mettre en
lumière les programmes qui doivent
éclairer les programmes à l'aune de la
rigueur économique de la et même les
lecteurs qui n'a pas fait de dix ans
analyse économique qui n'a pas docteur
en économie des capable de voir si les
choses vont moins bien ou pas il regarde
le taux de chômage est là là à mettre au
crédit du bénéfice il ya un résultat on
était annoncé et on est à saisir si
c'est très intéressant parce que en
effet c'est la première fois dans toutes
les élections présidentielles auront se
sont joués sur le taux de chômage
et cette foi et cette fois alors que le
taux de chômage ont baissé ça c'est bien
sûr au dessous sur l'identité sur
d'autres problèmes parce que c'est les
traits du blabla dire que comme ça va
mieux on est passé à autre je serais
passée en même temps il ya deux points
il ya le taux de chômage a évolué à la
baisse mais je parlais du quoi qu'il en
coûte on a quand même une politique on
va dire les mots de crûment keynésienne
donc on relance a aidé à soutenir
l'économie donc il ya une relance très
forte donc la relance forcément
puisqu'on france a relancé fondée sur la
consommation donc on soutient la
consommation et donc on agit sur le
chômage à la base c'est tout à fait ce
qu'on observait tout à fait normal après
est ce que on s'est attaqué aux
structures certainement pas on est dans
du conjoncturel les politiques
keynésiennes c'est du court terme c'est
du conjoncturel ça marche à court terme
c'est très bien qu'elle n'avait rien dit
d'autre ces mesures doivent être
efficaces à court terme si c'est pas
fica ça court terme ce qu'ont fait les
gouvernements précédents c'est qu'on
remet sur la table les mêmes les mêmes
des mêmes des mêmes politiques et elles
n'ont pas d'efficacité on refait les
mêmes dépenses et on creuse le déficit
on creuse la dette et on ajoute du
problème au problème c'est là où est le
problème c'est que ici on a finalement
je dirais une accalmie de courte durée
sont tendus chômage ça c'est à pois et
puis puisqu'on regarder plus chômage
grâce à l'opposition et marine le pen a
très bien compris il a mis en avant quoi
le pouvoir d'achat depuis très tôt dans
sa dans sa campagne il était d'ailleurs
la préoccupation première des français
dans les sondages et nrdc mais qui peut
refuser en travailleur plus ou moins le
plus ou moins de chocolat plus ou moins
de pouvoir d'achat forcément va pas dire
non donc les lecteurs il faut un moment
voulu parler non pas comme un enfant
mais faut lui parler comme une personne
raisonnable en lui disant si on dépense
plus la facture se paiera bien enfin un
président de la république françois
hollande pour ne pas le citer avait un
jour échappés cette phrase adam qui lui
disaient mais les transports publics etc
mais madame c'est l'état qui paye ne
vous inquiétez pas c'est gratuit c'est
l'état qui paye mais l'état c'est moi
l'état se sont tous les contribuables
c'est l'état qui paye un président de la
république et donc la ccl pas c'est pas
rationnel il faut il ne faut pas
infantiliser les savoirs d'achat c'est
quand même une préoccupation des
français qui est devenu prioritaire du
fait d'une situation aussi conjoncturel
parce que il ya eu la guerre en ukraine
ça fait augmenter les prix il ya aussi
une politique monétaire qui a conduit à
une certaine inflation qui structurait
le ou conjoncturelles on sait pas on va
voir comment ce à dire que vous êtes
aujourd'hui oui
pour la dette pour s'arrête aussi des
mesures qui ont été proposées on pouvoir
d'achat parce qu'il y avait en face une
conjoncture une conjoncture défavorable
en terme
d'augmentation des prix
souci en france on voit depuis plusieurs
années c'est qu'on arrive un certain
seuil de sa mère un plafond nous allons
tourner je parle en est aux alentours d
2400 euros nets à peu près que les
entreprises ont du mal à franchir ça il
faut qu'on aille vers le résoudre parce
que toutes les toutes les annonces qui
ont été faites je vais augmenter les
salaires de 10% alors oui l'état peut
faire quelque chose on l'a bien fait
c'est pendant son enquête
vous qui avez pas possible c'est ce
qu'on a dit
c'est vous pouvez aller jusqu'à 3% les
deux laver mais au delà ça dépend des
entreprises et une entreprise il faut
quand même qu'elles dégagent des marges
pour pouvoir effectivement augmenter les
salaires mais on arrive et pourtant dieu
sait si on à baisser les charges sur les
entreprises on arrive quand même un
niveau où c'est compliqué pour les
entreprises d'aller au-delà donc le smic
mécaniquement augmente au dessus de 2000
2004 sans ça n'augmente plus en tout cas
pas dans les mêmes proportions et là on
se retrouve avec des gens qui ont peur
du déclassement donc il faut absolument
inciter les entreprises à redistribuer
on pas par le salaire alors
malheureusement quand on dit pas par le
salaire c'est dommage mais c'est vrai
qu'ils ont du mal à le faire ça d'où
l'idée de déprime l'ebit l'ebit d'eads
une enfant revient un petit peu sur ce
qu'avait dit un petit peu nicolas
sarkozy à un tiers un tiers un tiers un
tiers pour les actionnaires un tiers
pour l'investissement et un tiers pour
les salariés imposés aux entreprises qui
distribuent des dividendes dans
distribué aux salariés c'est une bonne
réponse au pouvoir d'achat que j'appelle
plus le reste à charge parce que le
pouvoir d'achat a malgré tout
factuellement augmenté pas suffisamment
par rapport aux dépenses c'est clair
donc c'est un reste à charge qui qui est
trop important et puis pour les petites
entreprises qui ne versent pas de
dividendes mais qui peuvent dégager des
bénéfices le triplement de la prime
macron je peux en train de vendre le
programme et j'ai on n'a pas d'autre
solution aujourd'hui oui mais
honnêtement honnêtement on n'a pas
d'autre solution est aujourd'hui pour
redistribuer l'argent produit par les
chefs d'entreprise et leurs salariés
mais quand véronique vous dis que
finalement le couac il enfin le quoi
qu'il en coûte vous augmentez quand même
les dépenses publiques en absolument
rapport dont clic et si vous répondez
comment véronique vous dis que
finalement on pourra plus alors espérons
le rares étaient les lycées un gain très
exactement ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à
jusqu'à la pandémie jusqu'à la pandémie
on avait commencé un petit peu à
rembourser la serviette à baisser la
dette et pour autant on avait libéré
l'entreprise et on avait quand même fait
pas mal de l'augmentation notamment des
minima sociaux donc on avait dépensé de
l'argent mais cet argent dépensé c'est
vrai revient après dans l'économique
d'une manière là effectivement on va
demander aux entreprises finalement de
faire une partie du job quelle heureuse
aurait dû faire déjà depuis faire quels
sont les fers j'ai pas de leçon à leurs
données mais si on veut que la société
aille bien ce fameux plafond de verre
dont les salaires il faut arriver à le
dépasser et faut tirer tous vers le haut
et il ya que les entrepreneurs qui
peuvent le faire les salaires seront
utiles nous nous donnerons notre boulot
ça a été de baisser leurs charges
considérablement maintenant
effectivement on va leur demander que ça
rééquilibre un peu donc oui on va faire
encore un petit peu de dettes je pense
dans les années qui viennent pas ce qui
est un soutien
nécessaire pour ceux qui sont au plus
bas de l'échelle parce que ces gens là
on peut pas le laisser honnêtement sur
la route il faut qu'on les aide on
reprend l'histoire du rsa qui a été très
mal expliqué le rsa les les 15 au 20
heures qu'on va demander aux
bénéficiaires du rsa c'est pas pour
travailler gratuitement c'est simplement
pour qu'on leur donne un parcours de
réinsertion vient l'information et que
via la formation aujourd'hui alors que
c'est prévu dans les statuts de la
locataire du rsa 60% d'entre eux ne
bénéficient pas de formation pour
pouvoir retrouver de l'emploi et du
travail s'est complètement anormal
d'exception dans les divines puisque
nous avons la chance d'insertion
activités je ferme la parenthèse du
jeu
je vous dis ça donc j'essaye aussi de
rétablir région toutes ces actions là
elles vont elles vont nourrir on
l'espère effectivement un pouvoir
d'achat un peu retrouvé une consommation
meyer qui va nous permettre de
rembourser la dette ce qui est prévu
dans le plan c'est bien partir de
2026 2025 2026 on commence à rembourser
la dette est ce que le disiez tout à
l'heure et vous avez raison c'est à dire
que dans une campagne électorale j'ai
c'est vrai que la question de la date
elle a été pratiquement absente
c'est son entraîneur l'a compris j'avais
juste une petite une question de vous
poser si vous permettez qu'allez vous
répondre aux syndicats parce que les
syndicats quand ils entendent parler une
prime ils disent non et oui c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas juste c'est pas
c'est pas juste parce que c'est ce ne
sera pas pour tout le monde donc c'est
pas équitable c'est ça pourrait paraître
c'est pas équitable ils vont demander
des augmentations de salaires ils sont
déjà sur la sur la logique de dire la
prime n'est pas juste il veut les
augmentations mais c'est le délire
serait divisé par une peine déjà résumé
heures c'est à ces questions je vais pas
me faire que des copains parce qu'il ya
ce que disent les syndicats au niveau
national et moi j'entends bien je suis
le premier à dire que je préfère les
salaires aux primes ou participation et
l'intéressement même si ces 6es du
pouvoir d'achat en plus je préfère les
salaires parce que ça compte pour la
retraite etc etc mais quand vous voyez
les amis quand vous voyez ça c'est au
niveau national ont raison mais quand
vous voyez au niveau des négociations de
branche
filière par filière ou entreprise par
entreprise les syndicats signe quand
même des augmentations de salaires des
fois qu'ils sont ridicules voire pas
d'augmentation de salaire du tout
donc moi je veux bien qu'ils reprochent
au gouvernement il sait pas le
gouvernement qu'augmenter les salaires
mais à ce moment là qu'ils se battent
pied à pied dans les entreprises pour
obtenir des augmentations de salaires
mais je sais une sablaise du syndicat de
l'action c'est à dire légèrement qui
quand même sont en décalage entre une
femme qui dit il sont là au niveau
national et ce qui est fait au niveau
des entreprises un mot peut-être raphaël
sur les deuxième mandat
on a quelques exemples historiques de
gaulle
mitterrand chirac ça n'a pas été des
grosses réussites généralement c'est
d'abord d'abord il ya ça dure deux ans
et puis après il ya une crise
dogo le diabète 68 qui lui savent
toutefois qu'ils feraient qu il ne finit
pas son septennat
mitterrand il ya heavy rocard président
a depuis rompu il ya la cohabitation et
puis chirac est la défaite au référendum
de 2005 c'est compliqué d deuxième
mandat c'est très cool ça pourrait être
formidable parce qu'on n'y a pas il n'ya
pas le spectre de réélection mais on
s'attend tout le monde fait un peu
n'importe quoi parce qu'on sait
justement que le président tu ne plus
pouvoir à la fois en fait tout dépend de
la configuration politique qui
apparaîtra en 19 jan je pense ça c'est
ça c'est un point important si emmanuel
macron année encore ce que je viens
n'est peut-être pas forcément très
scientifiquement juste mais on peut dire
que si manu macron à une très forte
majorité
il risque d'être pris dans ce mouvement
de qui est qu'il a eue dans le rang
premier quinquennat blanc qui a été qui
a été un petit peu
on va dire un peu paralysés mais en
ayant une trop forte majorité ça c'est
ma conviction personnelle en ayant trop
forte majorité il risque d'être un petit
peu englué un peu noyé c'est à dire ne
pas avoir à faire l'effort de dossiers
de négocier alors que s'il a une
majorité un petit peu plus faible il
sera ce comme vous disiez tout à l'heure
mais sur un autre point il sera
peut-être obligé d'aller chercher des
appuis des renforts dans d'autres partis
et de négocier là encore sur quelques
points importants et peut-être je dis
bien peut-être là c'est un voeu je sais
pas si je peux dire un peu mais
peut-être qu'avec cette configuration
politique ça va donner un nouveau
souffle et peut-être en fait nous sur le
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est peut-être
plus finalement le nouveau souffle
démocratique qui pourrait
sur le pouvoir d'achat sur l'éducation
la science et la santé ce sont des
détails matin important mais ce n'est
pas moi ce n'est pas finalement mon
domaine de spécialité masse qui
m'intéressent simple vous pouvez pas
bougé je lisais les jo sur la réforme de
la retraite par contre même si les
décideurs d'intérêt partners ou bien été
mobilisés le kanak week autres venant
voler quand tu veux mais je n'avais
jours je fais plus compliqué mais tout
leur mystère troublant je vaux oui
l'enjeu fait enfin l'un des enjeux
principaux de ce nouveau quinquennat
sera justement de retrouver les outils
de pour redonner un souffle démocratique
et ça je pense que c'est le plus
important mais c'est intéressant ce que
je dis parce que si on se souvienne
mitterrand 88 littéraire qui viendrait
très lui dit il faudrait pas de trop
fortes majorités socialistes à
l'assemblée il à dire a été entendue
parce qu'il a une majorité relative et
rocha a été obligé d'aller rechercher
d'aider des voix pour une voix c'est
assez intéressant il ya plusieurs lieux
vie et vous avez raison moi je suis
assez d'accord elle tend partisans la
proportionnelle je vais pas aller contre
vous mais il ya ce levier effectivement
parlementaires ont des gens s'il ya un
vrai débat parlementaire fort les gens
vont ils finalement on est quand même
représenté bon
alors que là pour le coup c'est pourrait
que c'était pas normal que marine le pen
est celle des groupes à l'assemblée
nationale alors les gens me disent bah
oui mais la présenter des galas ils sont
fait battre ok enfin il ya quand même
c'est tout à fait anormal bon ça c'est
le premier point des lèvres losier damas
plus de vos députés socialistes que
député rnd traître et deuxième levier
c'est ce qu'on avait souvent initiées
avec des règles du jeu qui sont cons pas
été totalement bonne qui va falloir
travailler comme la convention citoyenne
ça a été un premier point très important
tout la première phase d'apprentissage
des citoyens a été fait magnifiquement
par tous les scientifiques pour qu'ils
comprennent un petit peu l'enjeu de ce
dérèglement climatique la deuxième fois
je suis un petit peu plus dubitatif
qu'il m'en excuse mais quand on regarde
l'ensemble des auditions qui ont été
faites 94% des auditions étaient des
auditions faites avec des représentants
des associations des ong
environnementales et 6 % uniquement sûr
on va dire les filières économiques or
s'il ya bien des filières qu'il faut
engager dans la transition écologique
mais beaucoup plus fort encore qu'elles
ne le sont aujourd'hui et dieu sait s'il
y en a qui font le qui essaye de faire
le boulot c'est bien ces filières là
quand vous emmener la présidente de
l'association des 150 à flins chez
renault et qu'elle apprend de la bouche
de jean dominique senard que en 2025
renault ne fera plus de véhicules à
moteur thermique ça prouve bien qu'ils
n'ont pas été interrogés ces gens là il
faut qu'ils l'utilisent il aurait fallu
qu'ils aident par exemple au cerib aussi
au centre de recherches de l'industrie
du béton sans d'études et de recherches
pour voir qu'aujourd'hui on propres
produits du béton qui capturent le co2
enfin y'a plein les industriels sont
arrivés à un moment où de toute façon et
non plus le chemin et fleurs il faut
dire m
factory
on a commencé à aborder de pardon je
rajouter une chose sur le sur la
configuration de l'assemblée nationale
mais justement sert 3 août voire la
violence juste un petit jingle comme ça
c'est le troisième tour justement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors selon lui après un petit comme ça
et après tu es de musique vous lance
avec une assemblée beaucoup plus en plus
hétérogènes ferme beaucoup plus
représentatif ce qui est intéressant
aussi notamment pour vous c'est que le
parlement pourra peut-être peut-être
mieux assurer son rôle aussi de précieux
rôle du parlement parce que c'est vrai
que ça y est les plus forts qu'ils aient
des problèmes aussi le parlement vote la
loi mais c'est avec la partie contrôle
de l'action gouvernementale est souvent
passé sous cette société mais la selle
c'est un reste un voeu qui est qu'elle
vote mais oui il ya là il ya la réalité
de ce qui va se passer les 12 et 19 juin
prochains c'est à dire que jusqu'à
présent dans l'histoire de la vème
république les français ont toujours
voté au donner une majorité au président
en place une majorité forte il ya on va
pas revenir sur la règle des 12 et demi
de mêlée qui est quand même qui fait que
si on a on avait je crois un peu plus de
peu près 60% d'abstention en 2017 donc
il faut au moins 25% des voix pour ce
matin au deuxième tour on va pas revenir
sur la règle de financement des partis
qu'il faut que vous tous et si vous avez
plus d'un pour cent un héros 30 par
électeur ce qui est quand même important
pour des partis qui aujourd'hui sont en
faillite et plus de et si vous avez 25
élus ça vous fait à peu près un million
d'euros donc il ya il ya des intérêts
qu'il faut que les parties vont se
présenter et que là on a un sondage
quand même qu'il qui donne qui donne une
grosse majorité à au président de
république oui ça se son message
probablement je pense que c'est un peu
tôt mais mais à la limite et je vais
vous rejoindre quel que soit le résultat
oui je pense que je pense sincèrement
que les français vont quand même donné
une majorité
présents la république souhaitait voilà
pour qu'il puisse gouverner j'espère
après effectivement
un cas personnel est prêté le plateau on
regarde jusque-là ce vote va avoir afin
de devenir mon enders
non mais on voit dans les premiers
sondages c'est peut-être un peu tôt mais
on voit effectivement que là pour le
coup il ya une vraie représentativité
notamment des électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon est une vraie plus que en 2007
et une vraie représentativité pour la
première fois du rassemblement national
avec un aux alentours de 70 députés
voilà ce qui serait très bien normal que
cette donc le parlement va pouvoir
fonctionner un petit peu plus
normalement qui n'a fonctionné sur le
contrôle je vois pas simplement un outil
il a j'appelle tous les corps
préfectoral
travail avec les députés là dessus est
un outil qui a été mis en place par mail
et montchanin qui est un outil
intéressant pour une fois c'est
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
département par département vous pouvez
voir très exactement dans les différents
sujets qui vous qui vous intéressent que
ce soit l'éducation que ce soit
l'économie ce qui avance qui n'avance
pas ce qui serait intéressant de faire
j'ai pas encore réussi à faire mais je
ne désespère pas de lait de les
convaincre c'est de travailler au moins
les députés avec avec les services
préfectoraux pour analyser ces résultats
la voir où il ya un déficit à quoi est
dû le déficit est ce qu'il est dû à un
manque de présence des services
déconcentrés de l'état qui peuvent pas
développer les politiques publiques
suffisamment ou est ce qu'il ya une
opposition ça peut arriver de certains
élus locaux qui n'ont pas assez vite
dans leur développement et une fois
qu'on a analysé ça on peut amener les
corps et il faut qu'on travaille
beaucoup plus avec les services
déconcentrés de l'état sur les
territoires pour que les politiques
publiques les gens les voient dans leur
quotidien
communiquer dessus oui je sais mais bon
ce qu'il faudrait aussi c'est que les
autres réintéresse à 7 cette élection
législative et qu'on se réintéresse à
nos députés qui sont importants et la
plupart du temps plutôt intelligent et
brillant et qu'on arrête
systématiquement tous les partis
politiques de mettre en avant des
espèces de consultation citoyenne qui
naîtrait tous les jours en disant bah
voilà ce que l'on pêche l'autre on met
bien sûr que si à quoi sert de délire
monsieur si de toute façon on se fout de
ce qu'il dit et de ce qu'ils veulent
parce qu'on dise ou fasse on va revenir
on va réunir 150 personnes qui ne
connaissent rien à rien qu'ils vont
donner un avis et voilà ça n'a aucun
sens soit on arrête la députation et
puis on dit on fait des causes nobles
c'est un peu plus simple
vous poser mais il ya quand même
peut-être besoin de régénérer la vie
démocratique on régénère tous les cinq
ans et ils prennent leur public petit
souci vous reviendrez s'ils ont envie de
régénérer au bout d'un ou deux ans ya
aucun problème j'adhère les députés sont
légitimes quels qu'ils soient ils ont
été élus aucun député en france ne vole
son élection ça met de la volée est
invalidée ça arrive très de façon très
rare donc laissons les députés jeu
je sais pas si les 13 millions de
français qui n'ont pas voté dimanche
sont d'accord avec vous je pense qu'il
ya un équilibre à trouver entre oui il
ya des représentants il faut une
démocratie représentative mais il ya
aussi une démocratie participative à
avoir en prenant l'exemple il ya des
choses qui se font au niveau local qui
sont qui permettent aux citoyens
municipaux notamment de participer je
pense notamment à certaines mairies qui
mettent en place des budgets
participatifs un petit clin d'oeil à
elancourt qui vient de mettre en place
son budget participatif
aujourd'hui je pense que les citoyens et
ça explique en partie peut être la
montée des extrêmes de aussi
l'abstention ça explique aussi en partie
la crise des gis les jeunes je pense que
les français aujourd'hui s'intéresse à
la question politique veulent faire la
politique ils veulent participer aux
décisions publiques ils veulent
participer à la décision qui les
concerne à 20 mètres de chez eux c'était
effectivement ça n'a pas d'intérêt
l'hymne national membre fo l'écart était
donc très bien faisons des trucs dans
les municipalités mais arrêtons de
demander l'avis des gens pour savoir si
faune on va pas demander à tous à tout
le monde s qui fut nous faut un deuxième
porte avions j'espère que non non mais
sur scène la question lorsqu'on les a
opposés aux règlements ne
vous êtes opposés mais oui mais le
référendum de la constitution prévoit
des cas assez rare de raids de
référendum et tant mieux
il ya des situations des décisions je
pense notamment des sujets sociétaux
important oui il n'est pas inutile et
interroger les français pour savoir
avait effectivement ce qu'ils en pensent
et ce qu'ils veulent la preuve d'un
groupe la grosse erreur en 2005 même si
j'étais désespéré maastricht c'est
d'être revenu sur
les hôtes et les français ses salles
dangers du référendum les français
marine le pen fait dans son programme
s'assied sur le droit finalement sur le
conseil constitutionnel sur notre façon
moi je vais gouverner et de réussir un
homme là on a effectivement plus besoin
de l'assemblée nationale et sénat est-ce
que vous car c'est à peine 2 eux
auraient été abolie avec avec vous
conseille dans les villages et dans les
trucs nos consultations citoyennes
encore une fois de faire annuler jeudi
de marines il faut des qualités mais
fait dire ce serait ridicule après je
pense qu'il faut effectivement une
petite dose quand même ne participe à
une dose de participation citoyenne il
faut bien en établir les règles parce
que sur ce qu'on a vécu ce cas-ci nation
citoyenne personne n'a expliqué au
conventionnel une fois qu'ils avaient
fait leurs propositions qu à peu près un
tiers de leurs propositions ne dépendait
pas du gouvernement mais de l'europe
qu'un tiers des propositions je vous le
fais à la louche 1 était déjà en cours
d'application puisque voter dans
d'autres lots personne ne leur a dit ça
et que le dernier tiers finalement c'est
ce qui a été voté à l'assemblée
nationale avec certaines mesures qui ont
été votées qui sont juste de l'ordre du
symbole et qui ne font pas beaucoup
baissé les gaz à effet de serre vous
seriez pour constitutionnaliser
peut-être les convention citoyenne je
n'en bouge pas pour le consul je suis
pour qu'on donne à chaque convention
qu'on fera sur un sujet particulier des
règles prescrites précisé de peinture
mais pourquoi pas une dominique merchet
titre et jason la cheville le test j'ai
fait un risque sur le rythme avec des
gels et jaune et gilet jaune dans une
salle bon là ça n'était pas tout entière
manger les jaunes j'ai fait un raid sur
le riz qu ils vont ok on va voir ça
marche le rite le riz que ça marche le
référendum décisif ce rituel marche que
si l'ensemble de la population accepte
le résultat est notamment ceux qui l'ont
demandé parce que si le résultat est en
leur défaveur il faut qu'il accepte donc
j'ai fait avec sur le risque
les gens n'ont pas voulu du riq
l'algérie jouer donc été la salle voilà
c'est comme les finalement c'est comme
l'élévation enfin je veux dire une fois
que l'élection et hyde a été faite une
fois qu'elle est validée par le conseil
constitutionnel
mais c'est bien qu'une majorité de
français l'a voulu donc si vous faites
des des conventions citoyenne si vous
faites des référendums pour que
finalement le une fois la question posée
ça n'aille pas dans le sens d'un certain
nombre qui disent banon n'est pas
d'accord on trouvera toujours à
contester n'importe quelle décision
qu'elle vienne des citoyens ou des
politiques internes parce qu'il doit
malheureusement peu plus de temps la
recomposition politique qu'on a vu et
quand même pendant pendant cette
élection présidentielle
pour sait qu'elle va s'accélérer avec
les avec législatives c'est est ce que
par exemple dlr on voit déjà il ya déjà
des disques des présidents de régions
comme la pression des pays de loire
comme le président de la région route
est une véritable dream team avec
jeannot mélenchon finale où ça va être
magnifique ca c
et puis ils ont intérêt à présenter des
candidats encore un tout ce
drapeau c'est plutôt à la droite
cette droite a des fractures et en
réalité pas depuis l'avènement d'
emmanuel macron serait fait depuis
depuis la la fin de sarkozy veut
seulement depuis la fin du quinquennat
sarkozy parce qu'il ya une droite qui
est plus identitaire plus droitière
alors je dirais pas qu'elle est et
maurice tout le pénis mais ils ont des
points de convergence quand même assez
fort et puis à une droite qui est très
on va dire gaulliste social puisque
c'est tout le monde on appelle au
général de gaulle mais c'est vrai
gaulliste social qui est
effectivement beaucoup plus proche des
modèles macron qu'elle ne les fasse
finalement de la ligne ciotti et ce à un
moment ou un autre aura bien que les
clarifications se fasse
si on regarde comme ça la situation
actuelle de la france qu'elle sauve au
vous espoirs et vos craintes et titre
personnel je me risquerai pas mais ce
que je vois c'est que tant qu'analyste
tant qu'analyste mais les espoirs et les
craintes les espoirs c'est qu'on remette
les lecteurs au centre du débat qu'on
mette un peu l'église au milieu du
village comme on dit vulgairement mais
parce que là je pense que mais
sincèrement et qu'on aime les hommes
politiques qui mettent les tic j'entends
du emmanuel macron un mot match m'a
vraiment choquée mais dans le bon sens
du terme c'est la bienveillance un homme
politique bienveillance apparaît
tellement désuets mais c'est le sel de
de la politique c'est la bienveillance
c'est prouvé qu'il a l'intérêt général
chevillée au corps de barive et à
convaincre alors je ne dis pas qu'il a
fait je ne nierai pas mais qui au moins
cette intention est là a priori la tâche
est assez aisé d'avoir l'intention de
faire le mieux est d'être bienveillant
de rassembler de reconstruire tout ce
que vous voulez sauf que ma crainte pour
oeil sur la crainte et pour faire très
rapide c'est que au delà d'intention on
n'arrive pas à concrétiser l'intention
c'est à dire qu'on a on a donné dans le
cône hâtif on est dans les intentions
comme disent les gens du marketing de co
natif notre tension et la réalisation
l'effectif l'électeur tarte souvent à le
voir et c'est là où le politique est
chaud c'est que les lecteurs aient et on
promet on en est engagé une politique
est engagée par ses promesses mais
n'entretient pas les sports de ce que tu
ne peux laisser espérer enfin je ne sais
plus qui disait ça mais il est facile
d'entretenir l'espoir m'aider
plus grande que les sports a été
entretenue trop largement de son métier
[Musique]
en deux mots mac ma crainte ma seule
crainte c'est
la prolifération
l'expansion de ceux de ce mouvement qui
tend à
gagner finalement le résultat de la
démocratie c'est ce qui me fait le plus
peur et s'est ressoudé légitimation
contestations adressées au regard de ses
conseils plus personne dans les extrêmes
en tout cas jean charles je suis assez
d'avis de 2,7 à vie et qu'on arrête
aussi de peut-être dans les médias de
donner la parole à tort et à travers de
2,2 toute contestation devient presque
légitimement dit c'est merveilleux
regardez comme ils contestent et c'était
1 bat non c'est pas bien de contester sa
règle quand les choses ont été actés on
les accepte puis sinon on va voter cinq
ans plus tard faisait faut arrêter de
cette sorte de deux idéaux nisation du
monde et de la société qui est
absolument terrifiante fête ce week-end
il ya deux ans la première chose c'est
qu'effectivement le présent soit clair
sur l'action qui vaut même qui veut
mener et nous on a un devoir
d'explication et là je vous rejoins un
peu sur les médias quand on va sur les
médias qu alors si je suis content de
venir essayer parce que du coup je peux
le faire mais quand on va sur les médias
notamment nationaux les chaînes et où
les chaînes d'info on a en général quand
on est dans la majorité très peu le
loisir de s'expliquer dans la durée et
d'expliquer les choses comme il le comme
il le faut ça a été le cas pour la
réforme des retraites je regrette qu'on
n'ait pas abouti parce que pour moi
c'est la plus équitable une heure
travaillée donne droit à retraite - la
retraite par points pour moi c'est de la
shoah big équitable je ne dis pas que
c'est égalitaire j'aime pas le terme
d'égalité je préfère le terme d'équité
ça c'est la première chose explication
qu'on nous laisse le temps avec les
outils qui ont été mis en place par
mehdi de montchanin que tous les députés
du doubs qu'ils viennent quelle que soit
leur sensibilité politique sur leur
circonscription dans le département se
met à travailler avec les services
déconcentrés de l'état pour qu'on fasse
avancer les politiques publiques comme
l'a prévu l'état parce qu'après l'état
il faut qu'on contrôle de l'effectif en
action sur le terrain
qu'on soit beaucoup plus sur le terrain
pour expliquer et qu'on m'arrête dans
les partis dits radicaux les extrêmes de
effectivement nier toute légitimité à
quiconque et lui personne n'a nier la
légitimité de jean luc mélenchon quand
il a été élu à marseille avec plus de 66
% d'abstention d'accord personne n'a nié
les élus
quand elle a été élue si elle aussi avec
le même taux d'abstention donc je suis
désolé le gouvernement a été élu le
président est élu et bien élu nous enfin
en tout cas un autre niveau à faire ce
qu'il faut en tout cas vous parlez de
bienveillance moi c'est un petit peu mon
credo je passe beaucoup de temps à
expliquer les choses aux gens et quand
on explique les choses des gens sont pas
idiots ils comprennent et ça il faut
qu'on s'y attelle voilà un cap clair des
explications claires qu'on arrête
effectivement de faire le buzz dans les
médias et de se préoccuper uniquement de
l'audimat et qu'on ait une action sur le
terrain plus importante ça signifie
qu'on légifère un peu moins et nicolas
on va regarder ce qui va se passer on va
regarder ça m'intéressait dans les
yvelines activement pour ces élections
législatives
ont débuté
ma chronique portant sur 12 vous espérez
le grand chelem je n'en alors là pour
être honnête je n'en sais rien je ne
sais même pas pour moi j'espère je n'en
sais rien je ne me hasarderai à aucun
pronostic merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
gré des lots merci beaucoup a fait le
matin division bruno mediène sur charles
jeudi et nicolas landry et à très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de pfs
[Musique]